[Music]
in the first Resident Evil you play as
Jill Valentine or Chris Redfield part of
a special police unit known as the stars
alpha team which is an acronym for
special tactics and Rescue Service after
being sent to find Bravo squads who have
gone missing in the are clear mountains
you find the remains of many stars
members and I chased into a mansion by a
pack of rabid dogs alongside Barry
Burton and Captain Albert Wesker you
attempt to find out what the heck is
going on
Wesker along the way you find Rebecca
chambers who looks to be the only
surviving Bravo squad member but her
story is fleshed out until Resident Evil
0 a prequel to the events of this game
if it we'll get to that in a future
episode just remember I will shoot you
after a few jump scares and a bit of
blind look you stumble across what the
mansion is really concealing umbrella
corporations base of operations which is
creating a biological weapon known as
the t-virus hence the name biohazard in
Japan unexpectedly Albert Wesker
is exposed as a double agent working for
umbrella who is using leverage over
Barry's family to force him to betray
his buddies very well what do you know
oh don't blame Barry for everything
I hear that his better half and two
lovely daughters will be in danger if he
doesn't do everything I tell him to he
the jello Christ
whichever one you haven't been playing
us is imprisoned by Wesker and he
reveals that he has been ordered by his
superiors who enticed the Stars members
into Spencer mansion to be used as test
subjects against the mutilated creatures
to gather battle data zombies cross
Cerberus dogs hunters a giant snake an
overgrown Beanstalk Neptune the shark
and a huge spider make up the bulk of
t-virus empowered enemies with one final
addition the tyrant Wesker releases the
tyrant and is subsequently killed by the
Beast leaving Chris audial to fight it
don't come this way
Oh after a few iterations to the fight
it comes down to a face-to-face on the
helipad local 8 another stars member
bradmccartney from a nearby helicopter
just in time and you incinerate the
tyrant if all has gone well you escape
the mansion moments before it becomes
cinders with Jill Chris Barrie and
Rebecca in tow if everything didn't go
to plan you escape a lord and have the
blood of your squadmates on your hands
also Wesker is revealed to have survived
his certain death but at this point we
don't know how so that was it that was
Resident Evil in three minutes we'll be
uploading three-minute versions of all
the pivotal games in the Resident Evil
series so please click Subscribe and
help support our little channel I'm Adam
from PlayStation granade I'll see you
next time
[Music]